new in version four it's a kind of tight
of time so i will start directly with
that and version 4 came in a month or so
ago I don't remember it's two months ago
and one of the key features is that we
have improved the built-in libraries so
we'll added several libraries from these
modelica standard libraries where I show
there were mechanical components so on
including libraries for we're also the
existing libraries like the rotational
library translational library we have
added capabilities to model the thermal
properties of those systems and a
fundamental wave library which is
basically a the old J Omega method in
order to to make faster simulations of
mushy electrical machines and so on so
this means that that with these extended
libraries you can develop more systems
just out of the box then you could do
before but i will not really show
details there because the more
interesting addition is the system on
library store which i will spend quite
some time on so with a system allure for
we developed a system to to add licensed
libraries in a streamlined way
streamlined way so it's easy to install
additional libraries and that you do
from the library store and as i
mentioned in oh it says mexico here for
some reason it has probably because it's
a mexican that has developed this model
plug library and anyway in this today we
launch this model plug library so it's a
library for connecting actually to
arduino and so as you ask for robots i
think actually this has a small even
though you ask for some other type of
robot I imagine this is an example for
how you would use
the model plug library where you have a
in system already build up a system with
a control panel a robot arm and then
some filters here to get a smoother
drive of the system and at the end what
you will have is a system where you
connect a simulation model with a robot
arm so you have an input from the
control panel goes to the simulation
returns to the robot arm and if you look
at that in a I think yeah it will look
something like this so you will have a
connection where you use the model and
you have the library complete drag and
drop built this together to connect to
the Arduino board and communicate with
the system so you don't have to do any
programming at all you just use a
drag-and-drop library justices was with
a hydraulic library or the mechanical
lever and so on and then connect plug in
your green aboard and it kind of runs
and that came today so I don't have a
slide prepared for that so that was kind
of extra and information but the
connectivity session will discuss more
about that but one important thing that
we are is the hydraulic library so the
hydraulic library a applies of course
seem to a lot of different domains heavy
equipment is probably one of those where
you would most like to think of aircraft
automotive robotics and so on are all
systems that are heavily dependent on
hydraulic systems the library contains
components of valve cylinders and so on
so if I look at that oh sorry there we
go if i look at the library it has your
resource ample it has different valves I
can open vowels and see there's
directional control valves of different
types and like conventional solenoid
solenoid activation valves
and and so on proportional activated
vowels and so on so we have all these
different components and you can use
those to build up a system like a
cylinder motion system so if we look at
the hydraulic hydraulic library system
it will look like this where we have we
have a pump here which was driving at a
constant speed and that that is
basically driving a valve and depending
on how we can tour it goes to valve and
depending on how we control the valve
with the input signals there it will
either be in different positions where
we will do different operations and we
have a pressure relief valve and so on
and at the end what we activate here is
a mass that we try to move forth and
back so when you have these kind of
system it works just the same way as any
other system or modern model that I
simulate that and I have access to all
the components like the position sensor
so I can look at the open the position
sensor and see the position of the mass
how that is moving or I can access let's
say go to the look at the load [ __ ] all
that was the same the load speed or I
can go into any of the tanks look at the
pressure what I was a boring all the
tank of course is it will have a
constant pressure in this case like it
can go to pressure relief valve and look
at the leakage pressure mass flow and so
on and so forth so I have access to all
these variables and I can connect it as
you saw to other systems
we also added a smart cooling library
this yes it's a hydraulic library it's a
commercial library a paid library that
you have to pay extra for but this is
used to model cooling system especially
in automotive automotive applications so
if you want to model for instance
cooling fans or water pumps these are
included in this library and this
library by the way is developed by a
third party also an institute of
technology so if you are interested in
developing and deploying your own
libraries you can do that through the
library store now and they will be and
users will be able to buy them or if you
provide it for free to get downloaded
for free and then install them
automatically to automatically to sister
modeler a library that was available
from before so i will not really go into
that is the biochem library this model
here we have the biochem library it
basically enables you to do let's show
that a very simple example first simple
pathways that are biochem examples this
is the simplest possible biochemical
pathway to compounds glucose 6-phosphate
or however that is pronounced in english
or and fructose 6-phosphate that are
connected with some reaction here that
has some kind of parameters control that
governs the reaction and basically what
we simulated here is the transfer from
one to the other and basically the mass
balance between these two and as you go
you will develop more complicated more
complex systems like the metabolic
system which has a lot of these
compounds and you can also then add so
in these we have the liver we have the
cardiovascular system and we have the
blood plasma and each of those how have
those kind of meta or pathways that are
interconnected to each other and we can
do experiments in this case we have
insulin that we inject and we want to
see how insolent transfers through the
body and we can get something like this
where we will see a variation we do
simulations with different different
inputs and we'll get different outputs
on the level in saline and different
parts of the body but you can also do
and as I saw this I didn't plant this
but this is actually an interesting new
feature of system model where you can
all watch to play it where you can see
dynamic diagrams so this is when you
combine mathematic and system all now
the diagram that you saw this is the
diagram as the drag and drop in system
over but we have added now from
Mathematica in Mathematica you can
automatically get these kind of arrows
here let's show the flow of insulin in
this case in between different
compartments as the simulation goes on
and it's two different simulations 14
from a healthy patient and one from
someone with the disease so if I repeat
that you can see we are entering the
infusion there in the beginning and we
can see compare how these two behave
differently so now we can use this to
understand how a healthy patient is
transporting insulin compared to non
deceased or or disease patients
and if i have time i might show a little
bit larger example later on there's a
planar mechanics library also added
which is yes as a biochemist a free
library you can download that is
primarily for didactical purposes so for
education you can use that to do things
like a Newton's Cradle or similar things
they will that I showed in the previous
presentation was done with the plane and
mechanics libraries that's one example
and if you're especially interested in a
topic just stop me now just as I did
with the biochem I'll give it a bit of
explanation around that there's a system
dynamics library which is used for
systems that in I would say you're quite
different from the rest of the systems
that are typically developed in system
model it could be things like the
developing a system of an energy market
or in mark market see how how do we best
meet a demand depend depending on which
supply we have with raw material how
would we use that to meet demand and
maximize our profit or it could be more
logistic to see how do we transport oil
from A to B in the most efficient manner
it could be disease propagation that
might be interesting today with the
Ebola so like an influenza epidemic
where where you would see things like
this where you can can study how an
influence outbreak you have the blue the
green curve here is the non-infected
population the beginning no one is
infected and after well while we start
to get infected and I was there like two
weeks ago I started to get get here and
then you get sick or some of us get sick
and then after a while you get healthy
and this is like one or two days ago I
entered to the healthy population again
and so in this way you can use the model
to study what happens if we try to stop
the influenza from spreading in this
location or that part
how can i how can can we best prevent do
to prevent an epidemic or even more a
pandemic situation so that's the kind of
things to do with the system dynamics
library we have added a lot of help in
the in the help system has been vastly
improved so we added a documentation
center where everything is gathered
together so for instance if you want to
get started you click on get started and
it looks similar to mathematic as
documentation center where you will have
introductory videos tutorials and so on
and if we go to the question of how r
are the components documented then we
can go in let's say to the mechanical
system here look at the rotational
library and each library has the
documentation like this where you can
find let's say let's look at a component
like an energy here if I click on that I
will get a list of different features
that I could look at for instance I can
see examples in which is used in order
to understand the use of it so it
automatically all examples where it's
used and I can click into that example
learn more how is this example set up
what are the results I can open the
example simulate example and try it that
way so everything is cross-linked and
put together in ways so you can go from
either start from an example and see
find the different components or if you
start from a component find examples
that correspond to that that will show
you how to use it this is also available
from reference that wall from calm so
you can see the whole documentation from
there and look at it and that goes for
the built in libraries and everything
else too
I will not talk too much about this as
their there is a separate session for
that connectivity and deployment is a
really important part that we added to
system over and that's why it has a
separate session but basically it's a
way to do things like connecting input
devices so sometimes I'm bring a
quadricopter with me or a gamepad and
then I have a quadricopter that is
modeled in simulation center and I'll
use the gamepad and I can control it and
and drive the simulation from that so
that's one thing you might want to do
another thing is going the other way
around when you want to drive a physical
system from the model then you can do
that for instance by TCP based the
communication which is a standardized
and set and there's also added something
called functional mock-up interface
which is a way to export your models so
once you have the model in system order
and you want to use it in some other
hardware software you can export that in
the so called functional mock-up unit
which is a standard and is used by 30 40
50 other tools so you can import into
them like for instance and I very stand
and try real time for develop it for
real time applications and so on but
there is a separate as a separate
presentation of that another thing you
asked for how to get the equations into
mathematica I will show the other way
around first and because we added that
this system is to system mother for so
we have improved the integration to
mathematic a lot so things are much
smoother it's quicker to do things and
but one of the things is that we made it
possible to create models from
Mathematica so if we look at this system
here some North America assuming in
Mathematica you can define
state-space system and transverse
systems like this and then with them all
with a we added a function w a great
model that takes the mathematica system
and creates a corresponding model with
the name you give it so if i press shift
enter here what will happen is that this
is created and if i go to system modeler
i can now reuse this system within
system order like this kind of doesn't
make any sense to use this probably in
in the biochem a pathway here but in
that way i can start creating my own
components from Mathematica it could be
based on equations also so i could say
like creating a bouncing ball model with
typical mathematical equations adding
events setting initial equations and so
on and i can create that and i can
either i will get that up here what was
the name bouncing ball i get get that to
my model here but i can also simulate
that from within Mathematica yest as any
other simulation or model but more I
would say more importantly what you can
do is from from within mathematical
rather than using the graphical
drag-and-drop way to connect sometimes
it makes sense to programmatically
create your models and now you can use
doubles and connect components to do
connection so we will create something
called apps sign here and Willie we have
a list of components 1 c'mon kill a
witch is of the class apps one sign
which is of the class sign these classes
are more delicate classes from the
libraries within the model Cassandra
library and then we say some connections
that we want to connect sine sine dot y
with a dot you that's the two things we
want to do when you create this model
so yeah so this is Mathematica command
and you might wonder with this simple
example why would I like to do this okay
this would have been faster to connect
in the graphical user interface of
course right but suppose you have a
system let's say you have an electrical
system where you have different types of
electrical resistors with different
behaviors like faulty behaviors and so
on and you want to build a huge set of
different models where you will use this
faulty resistor in different
combinations at different places then
you can generate all these
programmatically to get a table or
models from within Mathematica rather
than to having to connect each and every
one of them by hand so you can get a
huge amount or models that you can
simulate and then test the behavior
no I don't think so but I actually don't
know you are know w does work on the rep
you yeah yeah and so you ask eggs asked
about also how do i get equations into
mathematica so there is a function here
we can query the model for for all that
was w sin we want w some model data I
guess rather so let's i went to the
helps the help from within mathematic is
the same where it's the same way as any
other Mathematica help of course so I
have the different functions here and i
can find WC model data and from CC model
data i can see i can query things like
give me the diagram there should be an
example of system equations here i guess
yeah so you asked for the model name and
system equations and you will get those
into mathematica and then you can start
manipulating this in Mathematica there
are several examples online where you
can download examples and try it out
where I download that I don't have that
prepared but we can look at that
afterwards if you like yep just like
kind of two minutes left I think
say that
so what is new this is a very fast we go
through like a selection of what's new
and and try to lift up to a higher level
the first is expanding the scope so
adding both built in libraries I didn't
really show examples of that but digital
library closes station or library
additional functionality to the
rotational translational library and so
on a focus put a lot of this new add-on
libraries that you can add functionality
among those two hydraulic library there
are also things in the way that you can
easier get started with it by adding the
documentation center yet again very
quick go through it but it is a very
important way to kind of gather things
together in more structured way than in
previous version there's also a lot of
small improvements in model center and
simulation center to make it easier for
instance how to structural parameters
and so on connectivity that's a will be
a separate presentation of that and I'll
get back to the dose in the last slide
and finally a a lot deeper integration
to mount with Mathematica where I
quickly for instance showed the dynamic
diagrams which perhaps would be easier
to see on there that way we have tags
with levels that go up and down rather
than looking at a plot there are the
programming creation of models but also
we have made sure that it's easier to
use other built-in functionality with
Mathematica that was available since
previous version including Mathematica
10 like using the gauges to visualize
your your system to make make that more
direct and there's enhanced control
system capabilities in Mathematica and
we'll make that easier to use together
with system owner and so on